dieser neue mob den es in der minecraft
1.9 version neben vielen anderen sachen
geben wird heißt service skates und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft heute spielen ein bisschen
jump und ich möchte euch bisschen was zu
einem thema erzählen was uns als
minecraft spieler und youtuber
eigentlich alle betrifft und zwar ist es
die minecraft 1.9
die erste version ich möchte euch im
heutigen video einfach mal erzählen
welche features zu mit der 1.9 kommen
damit ihr wirklich up to date seite noch
genau wisst was sonst alles kommt denn
es passiert aber viel mehr als nur zwei
hände richtig viel richtig gute sachen
gibt es auch und ich habe selbst ein
bisschen bemerkt dass ich zwar von der
1.9 gehört habe aber eigentlich so gar
keine ahnung hatte was genau da drin
vorkommt deswegen habe ich es mal
nachgeschaut hat recherchiert für euch
und möchtest euch heute in dem video
hier zusammenfassen so dass wir dann
alle auf einem kenntnisstand sind und
bis sie mehr darüber wissen es gibt im
allgemeinen änderungen in den kategorien
items gameplay allgemein oder general
und bei den mops also es gibt auch neue
monster welcher das ist welches monster
das ist sich euch danach ist es echt
irgendwelchen spacey sowie kevin ich
erzähle dass ich dann so wird sagen
gegen ende des videos als erstes
arbeiten wir uns mal von oben nach unten
durch und zwar zum thema gameplay ich
muss mich wirklich beeilen weil es in
echt viele änderungen fast zu kurz für
so ein video als allererstes zum thema
gameplays wird die duelle hand option
geben also man hat eine zweite hand das
war so ziemlich das einzige was ich über
die minecraft version wusste bisher
man kann dann auswählen welche hand die
starke hand ist also es gibt erst mal so
eine starke hand so eine haupt hand die
dann besondere funktionen hat also man
kann quasi aus wenn in minecraft ob man
jetzt linkshänder oder rechtshänder ist
das eigentlich als coole sache und es
muss man auch also man hat eine haupt
hand und eine neben hand also die hände
sind schon mal nicht gleichberechtigt
das ist eine ganz wichtige sache die man
wissen sollte wenn man sich zum beispiel
denkt dass man irgendwie hat ist die
welt im chaos untergehen wird weil leute
links und rechts vertragen so was geht
zum beispiel nicht
aber dazu gleich mehr hierunter gefallen
so wie sagt es gibt diese dominante hand
option dann möchte ich ein bisschen auf
die hände eingehen so ein bogen kann
genutzt werden auch wenn den item in der
anderen hand ist was wie ein bisschen
paradox klingt denn man muss die bogen
damit irgend einer hand spannen aber das
geht holt also zum beispiel jetzt in der
einheiten bogen hat in der haupt hand
und in der anderen hand eine fackel kann
man den bogen wohl trotz fackel in der
hand in anderen hand ein spannendes euch
in ganz coole sache sollte auch so sein
also man sollte jetzt nicht die andere
hand lernen müssen dass wir auch bis sie
blöd was auch ganz cool ist ist dass die
wird was auf mich so ein bisschen
beruhigt hat irgendwie ist das die
andere hand also die schwache hand
unsichtbar ist wenn ihr kein eitler drin
haltet wohlgemerkt
generell ist es so der aktuelle stand
der entwicklung es kann sein dass das
ändert aber dass die vorläufig
informationslage die hand ist unsichtbar
das ganz cool als ihr seid da nicht
irgendwie dann so dass wir so wie zwei
händen ausgestreckten händen links und
rechts home office und zombie
die schwache hand die ihr dann selbst
auswählen könnt wird unsichtbar damit
kommen wir schon zum nächsten fact ihr
könnt nämlich auswählen welche welche
hand bei euch die starke hand ist oder
die dominante hand
also wir können selbst entscheiden ob
ihr im links- oder rechtshänder sein
wollte und das funktioniert mit der
taste dabei die folge ist dass es ja
also standardmäßig ist dass die fw taste
um mit der taste die normalerweise keine
bewegung hat bei mir kommen slot
neunaber das eine andere geschichte
könnt ihr dann wechseln ob eure haupt
hand die linke oder die rechte hand sein
soll was euer gamepad dann wie gesagt
wir schon gemeint habe beeinflusst genau
ist es bei die fort das sieht dann zum
beispiel so aus also wenn es dass sie
themen eurer haupt hand keine
rechtsklick aktion hat wie zum beispiel
den pigs also in pekings rechtsklick
passiert nichts dann wird geguckt ob in
einer nebenhandlung items was eine
rechts reaktion hat wie zum beispiel
eine fackel und dann wird die
rechtspflege aktionen der neben hand
ausgeführt das ist ganz cool wenn man
dann zum beispiel wenn es in der höhle
ist und irgendwann hat in der einheit
mit pixeln hat fackeln muss man nicht
erst auf die fackeln wechseln um die zu
platzieren
sondern man kann das einfach einfach so
machen mit dem rechtsweg dann kann man
obwohl man in der einen hand eine pixel
kann platzieren finde ich das finde ich
cool zum beispiel ich glaube dadurch
wird farben deutlich entspannter also es
ist gar nicht so doof ich habe am anfang
ist gedacht die die 1.9 richtig ja keine
ahnung wieso eine zu viel innovation
edition sowohl einfach bisschen zu viel
gewollt haben so viel neues aber ich
glaube das ist eigentlich ein ganz gutes
teil sehr schön auch jetzt hier gerade
die alten chefs bekommen wichtig jetzt
fahren wir runter so dann wird es eine
status effekt schweben geben
der eintritt wenn man von kugeln des des
schalkers getroffen wird sich das
richtig ja genau bei von schulter
projektieren was ein schulchaos als ich
euch gleich noch das ist für displays
der tritt ein und hebt euch dann in die
luft also ihr habt quasi schweben als
status effekt in ihr hebt dann in die
luft so weiter diesen status effekt
harpstedt nach oben
relativ hoch habe ich sogar und das ist
an sich ist das ist an sich ein status
effekt ist eigentlich schon crazy das
kann man sich irgendwie realität
überhaupt nicht übertragen dann lasst
uns aber weitermachen mit den blöcken
denn die zeit rennt uns davon
es gibt einige neue blöcke unter anderem
viele in der farbe pink pink er lieder
meine ich nicht welche genau das genauso
sehen wir jetzt und zwar als aller
erstes mal gibt es einen blog der gras
fahrt heißen soll also grasser ich
glaube der ist einfach dafür da
damit man so ein bisschen besser
modellieren kann wenn in weg im gras da
sein soll
also das ist ein blog der s15
sechzehntel hoch also 15 16 blöcke also
es keinen ganzen block hoch und hat also
für im vergleich zu gras so eine leichte
vertiefung und ich glaube es einfach
dafür da dass man so einen weg bauen
kann
das amt weg bauen haben sie also für
alle städte bauer aus diversen minecraft
projekten da bisschen was gemacht
dann gibt es als nächstes neue purple
blöcke als neue liane blöcke die von der
der chorus pflanze die drive sind also
von der chorus fans quasi abgeleitet
sind
es hat richtig schwierig so aufweise ein
zugehen auf gameplay und hier drüben
das was die kurs panzer ist sehen wir
auch gleich noch ich hoffe dass wir mit
death match arena wo ein bisschen laufen
können um ein bisschen besser zu
erzählen
nein aber ich zu weit dann wird es auch
neue es wird paypal briggs geben also
nicht nur den den purple blog quasi der
ansicht so was ist wie queenstown
sondern es wird auch pappel briggs geben
mit diesem purple briggs also auch also
briggs sind zu ziegelstein als mit
solider ziegelsteine geben und mit nein
mit diesen liedern ziegelstein auch dann
liane treppen und li na ja alles
mögliche das zeug hält was man von
poppelsdorfer kennt so kann man als auch
mit liedern blöcken bauen kann ich ganz
cool
es wird auch enstone tricks geben also
von diesem ich weiß ja nicht welche
farbe hat entstehen noch mal es ist
nicht diese acht genau das ist dieser
dem mann im bett wars teilweise hat von
diesem enzym wird auf briggs geben also
auch entstand entstehen ich schwebe hier
also auch entstand ziegelstein leute
enstone ziel vielleicht formal die kiste
mitnehmen wenn das geht können wir das
machen
nein natürlich laufen geht nicht auch
mal oder auch die schwierigkeit von den
pisten modul geändert das ist jetzt auch
auf einmal fahrt ok krass wusste ich gar
nicht sich auch jetzt gerade so dass es
gibt diese enstone ziegel das sind neue
blöcke und es gibt weit glowing pohl
also quasi weiße leucht säule die
abhängig davon ob er jetzt horizontal
oder vertikal platziert dann einfach so
ein leuchtstreifen der luft sind also
ist alles was diese glowing pohl also
diese diese läuft solle jetzt einfach so
als teilchen leuchtenden teilchen in der
luft das ist ganz verrückt dann kommen
jetzt mal zu den items da gibt's als
aller erstes mal die chorus flut die ist
das item oder der drop der chorus
pflanze die kurs ist auch eine neuigkeit
ich dir vorstellen werde
kommt die frist jetzt erst mal ich
glaube wir werden diesen deathmatch
viele tode sterben
aber einfach wird so ein bisschen was
erzählen müssen aber das hier ein
bisschen feierlich bekommen bono war
weiter dann die chorus blume und es gibt
vier neue file typen unter anderem ein
typ der gegner zum leuchten bringt wenn
er getroffen wird und zwar ist es der
popstar sich das gerade wie heißt er
kann kurz weg laufen hier das ist der
spectral arrow also der spektrale feil
so hofft er mir da oben hinterher und
natürlich weg oder nicht ok also diese
spectral arrow wird leute irgendwie zum
zum zum leuchten bringen dann was auch
neu ist ist dass die leute dass die
pfeile mit porsches belegt werden können
das auch neue sache also kann zb
giftpfeile machen ok habe hat mich als
einer weggeklappt natürlich nicht mal
kurz so genau ihr könnt ihr mit porsche
tippen also quasi eintauchen in diese
passion cindy getränke und damit eben
dafür sorgen dass ein gegner bei 2
getroffen wird er dann auch immer
vergiftet ist usw dann kommen wir jetzt
leute wir können vielleicht gar nicht
mehr für die neuen welten eingehen
worauf ich aber auf jeden fall noch
eingehen sollten sind die mobs das
machen auf jeden fall noch mal und zwar
gibt es einen neuen motto dieser mob
wird leiter was geht dir mir für hits
glücklich diesmal an nähe gut dass das
mal anders gibt es nicht ich weiß ist
das der richtige jetzt heraus wird
nichts nichts machen gerade eben und
zwar ist es der der schulter also dieser
neue mob den es in der minecraft 1.9
version neben vielen anderen sachen
geben wird heißt schulter das steht für
shell locker oder schierker so dass ihm
die schuld seiner schalker schalker das
sieht aus der sieht aus wie ein lila
blog scheinbar und der kann auf dem
boden oder an wänden erscheinen unter
anderem erscheint in einem neuen dungeon
den star wohl gibt und wenn er angreift
öffnete er sich scheinbar und verschießt
feile welche sie aber nur in eine
richtung bewegen also bewegen sich
entweder so
nach oben oder nach unten oder links
rechts oder so in die tiefe nach vorne
nach hinten
die können sich schon mal nur auf einer
achse bewegen den kann man damit kommen
zu modellieren und so weiter pi pa po
können die aber ändern also in welche
richtung die pfeile schießen aber
scheinbar nur auf einer achse
dann kommen wir jetzt noch zu
abschließend zu den neuen welten die es
geben wird es auch so viele was du an
dieser minecraft version alles drin ist
es verrückt alter was geht denke ich mal
genau wie dieser spielername von dem
typen aber wir müssen noch ein bisschen
kämpfen und zwar als erstes den and city
dungeon also entstand dann schon so
kann's überfressen hat mich einfach
abgehauen und mich gesehen zu haben
nein bitte jetzt nicht gegenseitig rain
oh gott was ich machen was ich machen wo
gott das wird richtig knapp ich bin
gleich da ist noch wahrscheinlich krass
aber egal
diese runde geht es eben um defekts im
hintergrund deswegen erzähle ich euch
das noch kurz nz die dungeon sind wohl
baumhäuser aus enstone und neun blöcken
und in diesen and cities sport eben der
neue ob dieser schalker der diese
projektile verschießt der sowieso als
block tätigkeit eben angesprochen ab und
die diese and city dungeon generiert
sich wohl auf getrennten and islands
also es wird so and inseln geben
scheinbar im ende und auf dem schiff
bauen diese and cities genau und diese
diese l diese enteilen
die sind um das zentrale ende also wo
zum beispiel auch dann am ende der wurde
durch am ende hier wird der dreck mit
entspannten zweiter arrangiert und so
monat also ausnahmen für kleine mini
inseln auf diesen mini inseln gibt es
diese and city dungeons und es gibt noch
richtig viele leute
ich packe euch mal den linken die
beschreibung da könnt ihr euch noch an
lesen was ihr noch weiter darüber lässt
wissen wollte es gibt auch viele
informationen
wenn das video gefallen hat was gern
like da wir sind es beim nächsten video
wieder haut rein macht es gut und
schreibt mal rein was ihr von diesen
neuerungen heißt ehrlich wenn die besser
behindert